walgreens the drugstore that's where you
get your condoms razors and give me
something else a diaphragm diaphragm no
why'd it like to say that we can't get
those of walgreens yeah okay if they
have a fitting you got to go to a go
it's like oh they don't do the cooking
on the co-main to me oh all right all
right your halloween cam hot Halloween
candy razors not your diet let's do not
good occasionally cheezits if you want
to spend $18 yeah she's yeah all right
all that good stuff it's a drugstore I
think you know that right Robert Reich
wrote a piece in Huffington Post talk
about all these corporations that are
moving their corporate headquarters all
over the place and walgreens is among
them uh they are moving their corporate
headquarters to Switzerland so all the
time this is I'm sort of summing up
Robert Reich Speece here and if you guys
tyt fans you know about him CEOs
complain that American corporations are
suffering under a larger tax burden than
their foreign competitors the official
corporate tax rate here is 39.1 percent
which is the highest uh but the
effective rate what corporations
actually pay after deductions is far
lower in 2010 corporations headquartered
in the u.s. paid a federal tax rate of
thirteen percent on their worldwide
income so quickly a little bit more info
about walgreens they're the largest
drugstore in the United States they've
8700 drugstores spread across the nation
and yet they're about to move to
Switzerland we've got some more info so
if they were to become a swiss
corporation they will do just as much
business in the United States it's not
going to change what they're doing here
but they're just not gonna pay as much
in US taxes the rest of us will have to
make up for the difference which will
probably cost taxpayers about four
billion over five years this means more
money for walgreens investors of course
the top executives which is why it's
large investors like those fine folks
over at Goldman Sachs have been pushing
for it so we've got a little more info
but before I bladder on any longer this
is just the way Marik is now right then
it's just simple as that sloop all yeah
everybody's looking for loophole I mean
we all are I mean the
from individuals on up but that what
Robert is it rykor rush i always say
rush but I said Reich which sounds like
I heard right now and that's probably
anyways Ronald rice we should find thank
you but no I think that's right but the
point that he had made was that if
they're going to be doing that that they
can't have the same kind of say that
they have as an American corporation
which is an excellent point right so you
can't sit on both sides of the fence
right so if you're gonna go over there
pay less in taxes you're not allowed to
influence the government the way they
have been doing and you've given me a
perfect segue so in 2010 walgreens got a
special provision in the dodd-frank act
limiting the fees banks are allowed to
charge merchants for credit card
transactions resulting in huge savings
for them if it became Swiss the days of
special provisions could be over since a
twenty ten election cycle walgreens
political action committee yeah
walgreens has a pack has spent over
almost a million bucks on federal
elections if it becomes a swiss
corporation it shouldn't be allowed to
spend a penny more again this is
according to rob a right i assume that
you are agreeing with mr. Ryan these I
just you know we've been talking about
patriotism and and being pro-american
and to me this this is an example of
where we should hold these corporations
and companies and CEO is accountable for
being anti-american I mean this doesn't
this doesnt sit I hope it does not going
to sit right with a lot of American
certainly doesn't sit right with me but
you know for companies that are making a
tremendous amount of money selling if
all of us the drugs in the Halloween
candy they have to be able to share the
burden in the taxpayers and and and for
some reason in this country i think the
the right is going to allow walgreens to
do this and say that this is you how can
you impose them or stop them or take
your federal laws into what we're doing
and this is a big problem right because
it's going to result in higher taxes for
those people who aren't supporting in it
right somebody has to make up for it
right and you know the real irony is is
that if they go to Switzerland they're
still gonna sell the shittiest chocolate
started still get a silver she's gonna
be [ __ ] yeah
not gonna get us anything they're gonna
pick up none of the Swiss sort of right
wow that's a good point stuff that is a
great point as part of this that
corporations have just run so amok that
nobody plays by any rules whatsoever
look we admit Romney running for
president a guy who admitted to having
all this money in the cayman islands
again not illegal so what they're doing
not my goal I know but we have no
ethical standards so it's as if we
couldn't find a guy the Republicans
couldn't find a guy to run for president
that didn't have money hiding in another
country yeah so is it that we just it's
systemic we expected where is that
outcry to where is that outcry from his
own party that's saying this is
unacceptable this is unamerican yet when
we go back to you know the Lewinsky
scandal and reachable enough right that
happens in the White House so I
absolutely agree I it's always baffled
me that that Republicans work against
their best interests and it happens all
the time where they're voting against
their best interests and you know for
people who don't want to pay that much
taxes then you should hold the companies
that are making billions and billions or
trillions of dollars tonight and why
don't they exactly why don't know
because are they afraid of them in some
way I'll be afraid that it's gonna bite
them back I to me it seems like it goes
back to this government you know stay
out of stay out of my business stay out
of my affairs me it's the same with
environment I look different so much I
wanted out of my affairs and I want to
hide my money except when it comes to
roads and schools abortion rights you
know those constants yeah yeah final
thought on this is part of this stuff
when you talk about all the money stuff
in the corporation stuff that there's
just nothing sexy about this topic so
it's easier to talk about all the other
like if you were if we were talking
about abortion people who would get very
passionate or if we're talk about the
death penalty or even immigration but
this kind of thing where you're talking
about taxes a company like it just has
no actually they don't electricity
because they are influenced yes if they
if they maintain an influence where they
don't deserve and influence or gain
right to an influence anymore that
impacts all those other sexy things
right so that makes this doubly worse
it's compounded that that we don't we
don't talk about enough because it's not
sexy yet but then they influenced right
number
yeah you know but but it all all those
numbers all those numbers mean a lot
yeah to everyone's right somebody sent
me a picture when they had a Mitch
McConnell wearing logos of all of the
other because logos all the companies
that give him money and they said
wouldn't it be great if our lawmakers
were forced to put on the logo in
patches on their jackets of who's giving
them money like a NASCAR race right love
that idea right it's a rain i'm pretty
transparent yeah it's pretty grab me a
NASCAR that's what they do they've got
uncle's every inch of them is covered in
logos well guess what our politicians
are exacting my same that would be great
yeah that was doing great all right
let's let's make a movement for that